well I don't think that I don't see
hedge funds is being particularly
detrimental you know they're just
they're there hedge funds is a very
broad category that represents different
investment strategies now one of the one
of the things that is true is that hedge
funds rely on complicated securities
trading complicated derivative
securities which people don't understand
very well and they rely on high degrees
of leverage so if they have you know a
billion dollars in their hedge fund they
might borrow as much as 30 billion
dollars to to trade with and so their
strategies are backed by high amounts of
leverage and that creates some problems
but what we've what we've learned is
that the investment banks were were very
highly leveraged as well some some by 35
or 36 21 and so that means that if your
leverage that heavily when in when
markets head down you can be you can be
brought to your knees very quickly it's
like having it's like having only three
percent equity in your home so if home
prices fall by 3% you might as well walk
away so that's that's that was the
status of bear stearns that's what
brought Bear Stearns down